Isis their influence in the Middle East
grows and on Wednesday the president
announced to the nation but yet again
America would launch a military
intervention into Iraq our objective is
clear we will degrade and ultimately
destroy ISIL through a comprehensive and
sustained counterterrorism strategy as
Americans we welcome our responsibility
to lead yeah but do we welcome it in
this case or is it like when the printer
at work runs out of toner and there's no
one else around who can fix it oh
do I really have to take the lead on
this again nobody else nobody else
here's the problem almost everyone on
earth would like Isis gone and yet
understandably no one is eager to be the
one to deal with it which is why as
difficult as this might be Americans
need to come together and demand with
one voice that Peru should really do
something about this seriously Peru
seriously Isis Peru poses a threat to
the entire globe and you are just
sitting there life isn't just a
fairytale land of alpacas and pan flutes
Peru at some point you've got to pull
your weight and don't give me the whole
oh but John our population is the size
of Texas and the war on terror is a
hopeless geopolitical paradox that's
Peru and also it is not like
you've got better things to do I have
seen how you people spend your time if
you have a patch a lot of you need a lot
of us have taught practice its shape
maybe roll over
what about surf the Peruvian man has
straightened his head out Packer to do
just that
alpacas are from the Andean Highlands
are raised by Peruvians pisco the alpaca
wears a flotation vest outside and
surf's for a little while and then
eventually goes oh sure that looks fun
but playtime's over
Isis is a menace and it is 100% up to
you Peru to get rid of them then and
only then do you have permission to
clamber back on a surfboard with a
sopping wet alpaca